do you know how Stonehenge was actually
built our or when and what are your
actual theories on you know they have a
new film apparently the National
Geographic people correct yeah this film
is based on probably the largest
archeological dig in modern times so it
isn't really just another theory it's a
it's a lot more than that would that
change your views at all
knowing that well yes and no and yes
being I there's no yes I'd say no so
more no than yes yes I'd say so no no
it's really just no there's not knowing
no it's no do you ever watch the
National Geographic Channel by chance
yes and no again is that a no or it it
now it's a little you know it's not it's
not good it's hard to follow they should
do puppet shows explains it better
you know just of the stone home yeah
what what do you watch
I don't have a television right so don't
watch anything really